being familiar with your competitive
advantages and disadvantages will help
you position yourself among your
customers you may want to include this
in your pitch deck or someone else share
this information with your customers
what is your unique value now if you
know this answer it's gonna help you
shape your marketing plan your
advantages can be based on one of the
five PS of marketing let's look at this
the five PS of marketing our product
price promotion place and people know
these are gonna help you evaluate your
main advantages over your competitors
for products do you have any features
that others don't have
do you provide value in some way for
price are you able to bring the exact
same value but lower the price now
that'll be a great value to your
customers that are on a budget and for
promotion maybe have some unique
marketing channels that you use to
promote your business or to generate
sales for place do you have a unique
place you can sell your product maybe it
used to only be sold in stores and now
you can sell it online or vice versa and
finally we have people where do the
strengths of your team what are your
co-founders bring to the table that's
going to help make you successful now I
want you to take a few minutes to think
about your own competitive advantages
for your idea or you can use a barkman
if you don't have one go through each of
these and think about what your
advantages over your customer so for
product what features do you have that
your main competitor doesn't or are you
cheaper or more expensive than your main
competitor things like that now using
the blanks below fill in a competitive
advantage for each of the five PS of
marketing now be sure to save your
answer somewhere else because we'll be
using these again